you guys usually is it like a rolling
drinking party when you guys me there
talk to boats I mean that was that was
pretty crazy I'm quite surprised by that
no typically we're very very
professional although I did just drink a
whole kind of Diet Coke and I'm afraid
I'm gonna burp in the middle of your
interview that's okay
I'm good there is going to be a real
bourbon I hear is that true sorry I've
tried it's really good actually
yeah it is really good um yeah I think
you know Matthew from the first film has
kind of had this whole idea of having
products and props and costume from the
movie in selling it I've tried it it's
very good
all right how was the stunts look insane
and I heard you had a problem with you
struggled a little bit with the water
stunts well it's actually something that
I've done quite a lot now so I'm it's
better at it than I was it's cool I did
I am I don't think I struggled it's just
exhausting and it's just so so so tiring
and quite scary as well because the
thing is in those scenes it looks like I
can see but you can't see underwater
it's just blur so I'm kind of pretending
I can see you know far in the distance
and I can't so it was crazy it is crazy
it's crazy but it looks cool though and
by the Statesmen how are the Statesmen
and I hear they're they're tough guys
Channing and those guys are tough guys
yeah I'm still quite annoyed by the
outcome of my fight with Channing it's
yeah they are there they are very tough
and I because their front is the outcome
alcohol and alcohol business they have
lots more money than we do could you get
them in real life though could you get
them yeah I'd take honey I'll take Tatum
any day of the week
[Music]